The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so we
added another tool,
quickly I admit, last
time to our arsenal,
saying that if you've
got a system where you're
trying to do a
trajectory plan for
and your trajectory
optimizers are failing you,
because they're only guaranteed
to be local, locally good,
then there are class
of more globally more
complete algorithms that are
guaranteed to find a solution,
if it exists, based on
feasible motion planning.
So we talked about ROTs mostly.
I talked a little bit about
also the more discreet planning,
A*STAR and things like that.
OK, so, so far, our
methods are still
clumped in very distinct bins.
We still have our value
iteration type methods,
our dynamic programming
methods, which I love,
which give us policies over
the entire state space, so
global policies.
But they're stuck by--
they're cursed by the
curse of dimensionality.
So it only works for
low dimensional systems.
OK, we've been
talking also about--
and we've been talking about
policy search in general.
And I'm going to,
later in the class,
make a point that
that's not just
about designing trajectories.
I made it initially.
We'll make it more
compelling later.
But mostly what we've been
talking about other than that
has been falling under the
class of trajectory planning
and/or optimization.
OK.
And this is only locally
good but scales very nicely
to higher dimensional systems.
So you might ask, how
well does this scale?
I don't really think
there's a good limit.
I mean, it just depends on the
complexity of your problem.
People have used ROTs very
effectively five years ago
on 32-dimensional robots.
That's pretty darn good, right?
If I have a system where
the start and the goal
can be easily found,
Alex says we can do it
in thousands of dimensions.
If I have a system where
the only hope of-- if I have
a six-dimensional system
where the only hope of finding
my way from the
start to the goal
is by going through
this little channel,
then I told you that's going to
fail, even in low dimensions.
So it's a hard question
for me to specifically say
what class of system should
you expect this to work for.
But I think they're
the best tools
we have for higher
dimensional systems, OK.
So the big question I
want to address today
is whether these ideas,
which seem very local--
we were talking about
single trajectory planning--
can be used to design a
feedback policy that's
more broadly general, that's
valid over lots of areas
of the state space, OK.
Does that makes sense,
what I'm saying?
Yeah?
I'm saying I could design
a single trajectory,
but that's really only relevant
very close to the trajectory.
So let's make our
favorite picture.
Let's say I've designed
for the simple pendulum
a nice trajectory, which goes
up and gets me to the goal.
And that's good.
If I start here, I know
exactly what to do.
We talked about stabilizing
it with LTV LQR.
So that means if I start here or
here, I'm in pretty good shape.
If I'm smart enough to
index into the closest
point on the trajectory, then
maybe even starting here,
it's fine.
I'll just execute the second
half of that trajectory.
But what happens if I start over
here or if I start over here?
Probably, the controller
based on the linearization
is not going to have a lot
to say about the points that
are far from my trajectory.
So the goal today is to take
these methods that we've
been pretty happy
with for designing
trajectories, and even
stabilizing trajectories,
and see if we can make them
useful throughout the state
space, just to see how
well that can work.
OK, there's a couple of
ideas that I want to get to,
but first, I want to make
sure I say that there's
no hope of getting--
there's no magic bullet here.
So there's no hope of me
finding global optimal policies,
unless I'm willing to look
at every state/action pair.
I'm not going to
tell you that I can
use these trajectories
to just magically do
what value iteration
did in high dimensions.
That's not what I'm saying.
Unless you have some
analytical insight which
turns the problem into a linear
problem or something like that,
I'm not saying that I'm
going to give you globally
optimal policies.
What I'm trying to say is we
can get good enough policies,
potentially, using
these methods, OK.
So I just want to make sure I
make the point that we really
can't expect globally
optimal policies
unless we explore every
state/action pair, of maybe
if we have some
analytical insight.
OK, so the curse of
dimensionality is real.
It's not that some-- the
value iteration algorithm
is a little quirky.
It's got this problem
of dimensionality.
It's really not that at all.
It's not that somebody
hasn't just come up
with the right algorithm.
The problem is you can't know if
there's a better way unless you
look at every possible way.
That's the real problem.
I mean, so it might
be that I want
to find my way from the start
of the-- front of the room
to the back of
the room, and I've
got some cost function
which penalizes
for the number of steps I take.
But unless I go
down that third row,
I didn't know that
there was actually a--
see if I can say
something not ridiculous,
but some pot of
gold or something
in the middle of the third row.
And I just didn't
see it, and I'm never
going to see it unless
I go down the third row.
So you really can't
get around that.
So the goal is to really--
maybe we can efficiently
get good enough policies.
And I don't care about
optimality, per se.
I've said that before.
I just care about using
optimal control and the like
to turn these things into
computational problems.
OK?
So there's a couple ideas
out there that are relevant.
The first one sounds
a little silly,
but it's increasingly plausible.
Let's say my trajectory
optimizers or my planning
algorithms got so
fast, or maybe just
computers got so
fast that I didn't
have to do any work
in the algorithms,
that it takes me a
hundredth of a second
to design a trajectory from
the start to the goal here.
I've got a real time
execution task here.
Every, let's say,
hundredth of a second,
my control system's
asking me for a decision
about what to do.
But if I can plan fast
enough, and I find myself
in this state, then you
could just plan again.
You could really just,
every time you find yourself
in a new state, plan
a trajectory that's
going to get me to the goal.
If I find myself--
so if I'm executing this
trajectory and I get
pushed off on a
disturbance, no problem.
Every step, I'm just planning
a trajectory to the goal.
If you can plan--
if we teach the course
again in five years,
maybe that's the only answer.
I don't know.
If you can plan fast
enough, that really
is a beautiful answer.
For the most part, the
problems we've looked at so far
are not that easy that
you can plan that fast,
but there's a middle ground.
So this was basically
plan every dt.
There's a middle ground
that people use today a lot.
I mentioned it once before.
But a lot of times what we do
to make real time-- to make
the planning fast enough
to execute in real time
is a lot of times we'll
do some sort of receding
horizon problem.
So how's that going to work?
The simplest answer is,
for receding horizon,
I've got some long-term
cost function,
and I've got my total
cost function is from t
equals 0 to some t
final g of xu dt.
I could-- I did
it discrete time.
That's fine.
So n to capital N
for discrete time.
And let's say it takes me too
long to plan N steps ahead,
but I know I can plan three
steps ahead really fast.
So a lot of times people will
actually approximate that
with the problem of just looking
some finite receding horizon
step ahead.
And if you can--
if you're doing it at
every ti-- if at time 2,
you're asking for the
receding horizon plan,
then you can just
look from time 2.
So let's say my current time to
my current time plus 3 gx of u.
That could be an arbitrarily bad
estimate of my long-term cost,
of course.
If you're clever enough to have
a guess at the long-term cost,
then you can put in
some sort of estimate
of what j x from t plus 3 might
be, and that's going to help.
So for instance, let's
say I find myself
off my trajectory
somewhere over here,
and I'm willing to say
my planner's fast enough.
My controller's
running at 100 hertz.
And in a hundredth
of a second, I
can about solve
an optimal control
problem that's of half a
second in duration, let's say.
That's a reasonable thing.
Half a second along puts
me-- it would put me here.
So let's say I'm
going to design--
I'm going to use my
planner to design
a trajectory that gets me
back to this in half a second.
And then I use my cost
to go that I already
knew from this design
to get me to the goal.
That's one way to implement
what I just said, OK.
And it's not just talk.
I can show you a
good example of it.
So I showed you guys
this once before,
but let's just look
at it again quickly.
This is Pieter Abbeel's
and Andrew Ng's work
on the autonomous
helicopters, OK.
So they execute these
comically cool trajectories
with their helicopter.
The way they do it is actually,
they get a desired trajectory
from a human pilot,
and then they
stabilize that in real time.
They do-- he calls it
DDP, but it's actually
what we've been
calling iterative LQR.
I told you that a lot of people
blur the lines, unfortunately,
between those two.
So they do an iterative
LQR controller design,
and they decided that it's
fast enough that they can do it
three seconds into the future.
So they're doing exactly
these receding-- every dt
for that control
for that helicopter,
they're doing
iterative LQR to design
a trajectory that's
going to get me back
to my pilot's trajectory.
And they're running it every dt,
thinking three seconds ahead,
and they say, that's
comparable to the time of--
the dynamics of instability
for their helicopter.
Yeah.
Put it all together, and
you get this thing tracking
pretty cool trajectories, OK.
It took a lot of
good engineering
behind that, too, of
getting the model right
and getting the
helicopter right,
but it's pretty impressive.
OK, so if you can plan fast
enough-- and like I said,
in a few years, maybe the
planning algorithms are going
to be--
and the computers are
going to be so fast
and the planning
algorithms are going
to be so fast that we never
do value iteration anymore,
but I kind of doubt it.
I think that
there's always going
to be reasons to do
more global methods.
If you can plan fast
enough, even a little bit
into the future, that
it might be good enough
to just turn your
planner immediately
into a feedback policy.
OK.
We don't do that so
much in my group.
I think it's a good
idea, and it makes sense.
But I do think there's a
lot of other good ideas
out there on how to turn
your planners into policies.
OK, the next one is
multi-query planning.
Anybody know what
I mean by that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, that's
not what I mean.
You can imagine doing something
like that and it meaning this,
but--
so I spent relatively
little time on the ROTs,
but actually, it's one
of the tools we think
a lot about in my group now.
It's actually-- the only reason
I spend little time on it
is I think that seeing the
big idea in class is enough,
that the ideas are
so simple, that when
you do your problem
set and make it work,
that's the best way for
you to learn about it, OK.
So it's such a simple idea,
and it just works very well.
OK, so let's say we've got
these ROTs that we like,
we know and love.
And for the pendulum,
I showed you
a plot of the ROT trying to
find its way to the goal.
It started splintering
off lots of--
eventually, it'll find
some trajectory that
will find its way there,
but along the way,
it's generated
lots of trees that
do random things and
lots of paths that
didn't turn out to be useful.
And what you have is a web.
In this case, it's a tree.
If you run the ROT
once, you have a tree
of feasible trajectories
that you could
execute on the real robot.
It happens that one of
them got me from the start
to the goal in my initial
problem formulation.
OK, but instead of throwing all
that computation out and just
keeping the nominal trajectory,
I might as well store it.
If I get a new
problem, which is,
let's say I wanted to start
from here, like I said
and get to the
goal, then really,
all I need to do in my new
time, in my new planning problem
is connect back to
my old solution.
If I can find a new plan
that gets me back here,
then I can just ride the rest
of the solution into the goal.
Simultaneously, if
someone were to tell me
I want to get to
a different goal--
let's say I want to get
the system to the upright
with some velocity--
all I really need
to do is find a way
to connect from my old
plan to the new goal.
So as you design
these, the first start
to the goal planning
problem, where
you're designing
trees that try to get
as-- cover all over
the place, could
be potentially very painful.
We might take a long time
to find your way from start
to goal.
But if I want to solve a
new problem which is not
so different, then it could
be actually very efficient
to reuse your old
computation and do
a multi-query-- this is a
multi-query planning idea, OK.
And I think that idea is so
good that it's actually--
if you do this again
and again, you're
going to slowly end up with this
web of feasible trajectories
that you could execute.
People call it a roadmap.
When you have some network,
some graph of these feasible
trajectories, people
call it a roadmap.
If all you care about
is getting to the goal,
then all you need to do is
connect to your existing
roadmap and write
it to the goal.
If your roadmap is so rich that
once I connect to the roadmap,
there's actually a bunch
of different options,
bunch of different paths I could
take through the graph to get
there, well, then at least
you've got a discrete planning
problem, and you can do A*STAR
on it or something like this.
And effectively,
the trajectories
I've already generated
will turn this back
into a discrete
planning problem.
That idea is so good
that some people
believe it's the only
thing you need to do, OK.
There's a camp out there
that does these probabilistic
roadmaps that's--
Jean-Claude Latombe,
I think, is the head
of the camp,
started these ideas.
And they believe that you should
address a complicated motion
planning problem in two steps.
First you'll construct some
dense enough graph, a roadmap,
I guess I should call it.
And then once you've got it, you
just do your query phase, OK.
So let's think about that
in a configuration space.
I've got a bunch
of obstacles, and I
want to get myself from
some start to some goal.
All right, if I know
I'm going to be doing
a lot of these things,
then it actually
makes a lot of sense for
me to go ahead and build
a pretty good graph.
So before I even start to
solve the first problem,
let's just drop in a
lot of random samples
throughout the space, choose
uniformly, OK, at the space.
Every time I add a point in
the configuration space world,
they try to connect that
new point to the end
closest points with
simple strategies.
So I'll pick a point
at random, I'll
try to find the guys
that are close to it,
and I'll connect with it.
Pick a new point at random.
Oh, there's really only
one guy close to it.
I'll connect to it.
Pick another point.
Maybe these guys are connected.
And that's it.
And if I do it
enough, and then I
come up with a
pretty good roadmap--
maybe this guy was the one
that connects to everybody--
that when the query
phase comes along, again,
all you need to do is
connect to your roadmap.
I got a new query.
I just connect to my roadmap.
I do whatever my discrete
searching problem may--
A*STAR or whatever to
find a path from the start
to the goal, OK.
I actually think it's
a very beautiful idea
to have this web of possible
trajectories covering the state
space.
And then all it takes
at execution time
is connecting and then
executing your trajectory.
Now the probabilistic
roadmaps, again,
this step of connecting
nearby points
in under-actuated
systems might be hard.
Might be as hard
as finding the path
from the start to the goal.
So maybe what you
do here is actually
do a [? DR call ?] or
something to find that path,
or you do an RRT, or one
of any of the other methods
we've done to make these
initial connections.
And maybe to make them
feasible to execute,
you've got to do some trajectory
stabilization to get on that.
But if you can solve some
local planning problems,
then you can use these big
roadmap ideas to maybe do
more global behaviors, OK.
So again, I think multi-query
planning is a nice way
to go from local policies to
more globally valid policies.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I can see
that working pretty well
with a static obstacle field.
PROFESSOR: Good.
AUDIENCE: Could it move
[? moving ?] obstacles,
and might--
the roadmap might change?
PROFESSOR: Well, I
don't really know
what the proponents would say.
But if you know where
the obstacles are, then--
or if you even sense
where the obstacles are
going to be in a
receding horizon quickly,
then you could--
maybe this one's blocked, and
I can just take another path.
But if I have a rich
enough road map,
hopefully you can
get around that.
And the other
thing is, if I have
a model of how those
obstacles are changing,
then naively, that just adds one
dimension in time, let's say,
to my plan, and I just have to
do a higher dimensional plan.
But I think the case
you're thinking about
is if these things are
just moving on their own.
I don't have any good model.
I suddenly find
that I'm obstructed.
Then, again, you could
dynamically replan
or you could--
by either taking a different
path here or making a new edge
if you had to.
I don't think it breaks
the fundamental goal.
You could almost think of this
as having-- in a dynamic sense,
you could almost think
of this as having
a bunch of repertoires, a bunch
of things I know how to do.
So maybe if it's
a walking robot,
maybe I know how to
take a step here.
That's one of my edges.
I know how to execute that.
I know how to take a big step.
I know how to take a small step.
It's a repertoire of local
skills, local trajectories
in this case.
Then I just got to stitch them
together in the right way.
So that's a fairly
robust thing, even if--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: Given a rich
enough roadmap, would
you have problems finding--
choosing the best path
among those path nodes,
like discrete search?
PROFESSOR: The
discrete search, I
think in general, you should
think of as being unlimitedly--
basically unlimited.
I mean, compared to all these
continuous time methods,
it's very, very efficient.
People doing it on huge
collections of nodes very
efficiently, especially
if you can do A*STAR,
if you find a good heuristic.
I mean, this is
how you can go to--
to maybe overplay the title,
this is how you go to MapQuest
and you ask it to go from
Boston to California,
and it just happens.
These things are very fast,
even with a lot of nodes,
a lot of roads.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How did it compare
to [INAUDIBLE] discretize
in state space?
PROFESSOR: Good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So this--
very good question.
Let me answer that first,
and then I'll-- yeah.
So I almost talked about
this last time right
after I said, what happens
when you turn this state
space into buckets, how it's
a reasonable thing to try
but not very elegant.
I think these guys would have
put this topic immediately
after that, saying,
instead of discretizing
in some unnatural
grid maneuver, we're
discretizing here by
sampling randomly.
That has the benefit that
you could, for instance--
you can actually-- you don't
have to sample uniformly.
Maybe you care more about
things in this area.
You can bias your sampling
distribution, same way
you can add more grid cells
or something like that.
But the real benefit is that
it's a more continuous process.
It's not stuck in some
very discrete bins.
OK.
Sorry, second part
of your question.
AUDIENCE: Well, now
it would follow,
like if we have a discrete
[? board ?] and we can run any
of those algorithms on
[? value ?] [? iteration ?]
on top of it, [? we can ?]
[? find out? ?]
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
So why did I say A*STAR.
I should have said value
reason on the-- right?
Yeah.
Right.
I mean, A*STAR can be
faster than value iteration.
If you have a good heuristic,
you don't have to--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when you're
doing the sampling here--
PROFESSOR: Good.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --you were--
ROTs do this very
uniform sampling.
And you say you can
bias the sample.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But if
you're doing this
before you even do
your first path,
why don't you actually choose
[? optimal ?] [INAUDIBLE]??
Can't you do some kind of
[INAUDIBLE] diagram with this
and just say, I'm going to
test using the best I can find,
given that I have a
model of the world,
and then [? get them ?]
[? with sampling, ?] [? your ?]
[? subcontinuous ?]
time, and then you find--
why is the sampling
[? still ?] part of this--
PROFESSOR: Excellent point.
I think if the problem
permits that, then you
should absolutely do that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So then--
PROFESSOR: I think
even for the pendulum,
though, I wouldn't
know how to tell you
what the optimal sampling is,
because the way these things
connect are non-trivial.
They're subject to the
dynamic constraints.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if you could formulate
that and solve it
for this-- and maybe you can.
Maybe people have.
I don't know that.
I haven't seen that.
But then that sounds like a
very reasonable thing to do.
AUDIENCE: But it doesn't
have to be quick, right?
PROFESSOR: It doesn't
have to be quick--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
first time--
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: --can be
as slow as possible--
PROFESSOR: It could--
AUDIENCE: --because
you want it-- well--
PROFESSOR: Well, right.
AUDIENCE: --times the universe
can explode with that, but--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Take a chance to-- this
is, explore your system.
Build things that are good
in random places, and then
worry about
connecting them later.
Mm-hmm.
Really good.
OK.
So again, making
these connections
in under-actuated
systems is more subtle.
It might be that there's a
lot of one-way connections,
but we can still do--
we know how to do
graph search, OK.
But these are
generally good tools,
and they've been used a
lot in robotics lately.
These are-- the other ones, the
Rapidly Exploring Randomized
Trees, goes by RRTs.
These go by PRMs,
Probabilistic Roadmaps.
A lot of people seem to think
that they're competitors,
intellectual
competitors with RRTs,
and I don't think
that they are really.
I think the RRT
guys would just say,
well, you just use an RRT
to make the connections,
and the roadmap is
still a very good idea.
And I think RRTs
effectively make roadmaps.
So I think they're
very harmonious ideas.
Excellent.
So that's at least two ideas
to take these local trajectory
optimizers and turn them into
more of a feedback policy.
But there's a big one,
big one that I like a lot,
that I haven't said, OK.
So big I'm going to
go back to the left.
OK, let's say it's
idea number three--
these things aren't
perfectly orthogonal,
but this was the breakdown
I was most happy with, OK.
Feedback motion planning.
OK.
So, so far, we've talked
about building some trajectory
that we thought was good,
and then afterwards,
go through and stabilize
it with feedback.
That's not always
the best recipe,
because you could
imagine, for instance,
designing a controller that
locally looked very good
but was completely
unstablizable.
I go to then--
I'm done with this.
I say, perfect, my first
stage of my control design
picked this trajectory.
Now I'm going to run LTV
LQR on it to stabilize it.
And then I find out,
whoops, right there
it's not controllable
or something
and that my cost to
go function blows up.
Maybe my open loop
trajectory optimizer
told me to walk along
the side of a cliff
and wasn't really
paying attention
to the fact that
stabilizing that's hard.
Or maybe it was
saturating my actuators
the entire time-- that's
a very real possibility--
and left me no margin of control
to go back and stabilize it.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? putting ?] those edges down,
that it is actually feasible
to go from A to B, so--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's definitely feasible
to go from A to B,
but it doesn't say that--
nothing thought
about whether if I
get disturbed epsilon from
this, whether I can recover.
AUDIENCE: So you're
worried about the noise.
PROFESSOR: I'm worried
about noise, right.
So it's feasible for me to
walk along the side of a cliff,
but I wouldn't
want to be bumped.
If I know I'm
going to be bumped,
then I pick a
different path, OK.
So you can imagine-- for
maybe each of those examples,
you could imagine ways to try
to make the planning process
more--
let's say, OK, well, don't
use your full torque limits.
Use 90% of your torque limits.
That's a good idea.
That'll help.
But there's a more general
philosophy out there,
which is that you shouldn't
just do trajectory planning
and then stabilize it.
You should really be
planning with feedback,
if that makes any sense, OK.
Well, it'll make
sense in a minute.
There's a lot of
ways to present this.
I thought the best way would
be to start with a case
study, someone who--
a problem where people
really use this, OK.
There's been a
lot of people that
have been interested in
making robots juggle.
One of them's been
sitting in the room here.
The ones that did a lot of the
work I'm talking about here
is Dan Koditschek's camp.
OK.
So it's actually
very, very harmonious
with John's lecture
on running, and that's
why Koditschek's done
both, for instance.
Now let's think
about the problem
with making a robot juggle, OK.
So the first thing you
need to think about--
and let's make a
one-dimensional juggler, OK.
So we've got a paddle
here, constrained
to live in this plane, and we've
got a ball, also constrained
to live in that plane.
Yeah?
And your goal is to--
if this thing is in a rail,
it can only move vertically,
your goal is just
to move that paddle
to, say, stabilize
a bouncing height.
Let's say you've got
a desired height.
OK.
This is the 1-D juggler.
I think they call it the
line juggler by Martin
Buehler and Dan Koditschek.
Martin went on to build Big Dog
at VDI, and now he's at iRobot.
So these are famous guys, OK.
So the dynamics are pretty
simple to write down.
You have a mass of the ball.
You have some dynamics
of your paddle.
You assume that the
mass of the paddle
is much, much bigger
than the ball.
That simplifies some things.
And so now the dynamics are just
ballistic flight of the ball.
You need some trajectory.
Your control is to design
some trajectory of the paddle,
and then you have an impact
dynamics, which these guys use
an elastic model--
model it is an instantaneous
elastic collision
with a coefficient
of restitution.
That's a reasonable
collision model
if your energy is conserved.
And again, they assume that
when the collision happens,
the ball changes direction
and keeps 90% of its energy,
and the paddle was unaffected.
Relative to the mass of the
paddle, the ball is negligible.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] juggling
the balls are almost completely
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's true.
These are, I guess, not--
[? Philipp's ?] are completely
almost as hard as possible.
In his project, he
said he spent lots
of time trying to find
the perfect ball, which
was the perfectly machined,
very hard precision ball, yeah.
Compliant juggling, maybe
that's our next challenge
for robotics, squishy balls.
OK, good.
So it turns out they do a
really nice control design.
It turns out to be
very natural to--
the controller that they
come up with for the paddle
uses a mirror law.
Turns out if you can sense
the state of the ball
and you just do a distorted
mirror image of that ball,
then everything
gets really easy.
Your impacts always happen at 0.
It's at the same place.
And you can, just by
changing the velocity here,
you can roughly affect
the impact height.
So what they do is they can
nominally stabilize some limit
cycle with just
mirroring the ball,
and they add an extra term to
stabilize the energy to get it
to whatever height they want.
So they do a distorted mirror
image of ball trajectory plus--
the distortion is scaled by
some energy correcting term.
It's a beautiful thing.
Very, very simple controller.
Has a nice, very
stable solution.
In fact, I think they prove
it's globally stable for--
you can tell me if--
is it globally stable
in the 1-D case?
I think it probably is.
OK.
How do they prove
it's globally stable?
They do an apex to
apex return map.
And the same way we did for
the hopping models and all
the other models, these guys
were pushing the unimodal maps
and getting some global
stability results out of that.
That's why I think that they
had a global result, OK.
So it's actually exactly
like a hopping robot.
Just the ball's moving
instead of the robot.
OK, so they got a pretty good
controller for 1-D juggling,
and then they started
doing 2-D juggling.
I think I have the vi--
I don't have the video for
the 1-D juggling somehow,
but I do have the video
for the 2-D juggling.
Yeah, so here's your
2-D case showing off
doing two balls
at once, since all
that matters is the state of the
robot when the impact occurs.
So you might as well
do something else
during the other time, like
stabilize another ball.
And you can see that
actually, it turns out
to be pretty easy to get
stability in this plane,
just because if you tend to--
if you're too far
to this side, you
tend to get hit earlier, which
causes you to go out more
and vise versa.
So that stability
almost comes for free.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This is, I think,
vision off to the side.
I know it's vision
off to the side,
where they're tracking
the bright yellow balls.
If it had been
dark gray balls, it
might have been something else.
But the bright yellow tennis
balls suggests vision.
Yeah.
And they went on to
do the 3-D juggling.
This one was, I remember, in the
basement of the Michigan AI lab
when I was there,
behind that curtain.
It's always using the vision
sensing for the balls.
You could do you
pretty good things.
And then they got
so good that they
started doing other maneuvers
like catching and palming
and things like this, OK.
It actually turned out to be
the same, pretty much, control
derivation.
They just set the
desired energy to 0,
and suddenly they have
a catching controller.
And then this is palming when
they're doing their thing, OK.
And then they can get it back up
to catching with the same sort
of energy shaping.
And I should show you, you don't
actually need all that feedback
to do it.
You don't need to
sense the ball.
Here he is.
This is [? Phillips. ?]
We'll show the one
where he's pushing it so
you can tell who it is here.
Blind juggler.
So this is open loop
stable juggling.
You can see-- actually, do
you see the ball up there?
Yeah, it's going
to a stable height,
and he's moving it around.
He's got just a itty
little bit of concavity
in that plate, which gives
it all the passive stability
properties.
And you've got versions
where it's doing things off
to the side in 3-D
or in 2-D and--
yeah, so let's open loop stable.
So juggling is actually a really
cool problem for robotics.
It's led to a lot of nice
dynamic insights and party
tricks, I guess.
Yeah.
OK, so these guys said, we
got pretty good at juggling.
We can do a mirror law
to stabilize whatever
juggling height we want.
We've got a catching
controller also,
which has roughly
set the energy to 0
and just sort of does this step.
And they also had a
palming controller,
which was when the dynamics
were actually on the paddle,
they did a little bit
of different things
to be able to move it around
without it falling off
the paddle.
What they were left
with was this challenge.
And we've got these controllers,
which are good locally.
What do we do to make them
do more interesting things?
So they actually--
so if they want
to transition, for instance,
between the catching
and the palming-- the
bouncing and the palming,
they use their
catching controller.
Maybe they want to
avoid moving obstacles.
They want to do multiple balls.
They want to do
all these things.
They introduced a really
nice, beautiful picture
of feedback motion
planning using funnels.
OK, so every one of
those controllers
had the property that it
would take initial conditions
in state space and move them
to some more desirable state.
So for instance,
the ball hopping,
the ball could be anywhere here.
By applying this controller
for some finite amount of time,
when it's done, it's going to
be closer to its apex height.
In many cases, not
in the juggling case,
not in the experimental
juggling case--
and even in the model
one, I guess they do.
But in many cases, you actually
have Lyapunov functions
which describe the way that
convergence happens, OK,
but it's not strictly necessary.
So the idea is, let's think
about this thing as a funnel,
OK.
It takes lots of states in.
So this is initial states.
And after applying it for
some finite amount of time,
I'm going to be some--
you get some new final states.
And if my controller
was any good, then
hopefully the final states
are a smaller region
than the initial states.
So in some sense, this
is a geometric cartoon
for a Lyapunov function.
Lyapunov functions take my
state in, and descend down,
and will put me in
some other state, OK.
Experimentally, you can
also find these things,
even if you can't do
the Lyapunov function.
Experimentally, this input
is basically the basin
of attraction of my controller.
So if it was really
a basin of attraction
and it stabilized some fixed
point, then if I ran it
long enough that it was
asymptotically stable,
I'd call it a basin
of attraction.
Here I'm just going to run
it for some finite time.
So you have to be a little
careful calling it a basin,
but I think it's still
intuitive that this is the--
there's lots of names for this.
Another name for it is pre-image
in the motion planning world.
Lot people call this the
pre-image of our action.
This is, I guess,
the post-image, yeah.
These are the set
of states where
my controller is applicable.
I'm going to have a
funnel for the mirror law.
I'm going have a funnel
for my catching controller.
That takes a different
set of initial conditions
and gets me where I want to be.
And I have a funnel that
can allow my palming
to do different things, OK.
And I might even
have lots of funnels.
So I might have a different
funnel given the mirror law
where my desired energy is
4, versus the mirror law
where my desired energy is 6.
Maybe those should look
like different funnels.
So the picture that
these guys gave us--
this is Burridge, Rizzi,
and Koditschek, the guys.
Al Rizzi's at Boston
Dynamics also--
is that you can do
feedback motion planning
as a sequential composition
of funnels, yeah?
So if I want to get from
one state to another state,
and I don't have a single
controller that will get me
there, all I need to do is
reason about a set of these--
a sequence of these funnels for
which the first funnel takes me
from my initial conditions
into a domain where
my second funnel is applicable.
And then I can use
my second funnel
to get me somewhere else, and
then my third funnel maybe
will get me to my target.
So if my goal state is somewhere
abstractly here in state space,
that's not accessible
from any one--
I can't get from my initial
condition to my goal
with any one of my controllers.
I can sequence
these controllers,
just making sure that
the output of one funnel
is covered, completely
covered by the input
of the next funnel.
Then that's enough,
then, to turn this again,
to use these funnels
as an abstraction
to take away the
continuous problem
and give me a discrete planning
problem, which just says I just
need to go through this
funnel, through this funnel,
through this funnel, and
I can get to the goal, OK.
So in this case, they
did tasks like there
was a beam here that was--
they were bouncing on one side.
They wanted to be bouncing
on the other side.
So I think they had
one controller that
went over the top.
Then the beam got taller.
They had another one where it
caught it, brought it under,
started paddling again.
And these things just
fall naturally out.
This could be the catching.
Or this could be the--
yeah, catching.
This could be the palm, and
this could be my mirror again.
And I'm right back to
where I want to be, OK.
Very, very beautiful idea.
As far as I could tell,
everybody who read that paper
was enamored by it, and nobody's
really used it that much,
because there was
one critical problem.
Figuring out what those funnels
looked like are really hard.
So really, the only
issue, I think,
is that describing the basins
of attraction, let's say--
so if you read the Burridge,
Rizzi and Koditschek paper,
you'll see a ridiculous
number of scatter plots
where they put the
ball in this location,
they ran their
controller for a while,
and they determined
experimentally
whether it was in the basin of
attraction of this controller.
Yeah?
Ouch, right?
That's not what I want
to do with my time.
So if you're willing to do that,
then it's a workable method.
But I think today we've
got a better way to do it.
And my group, we've been
working on an implementation
of this feedback motion
planning idea, which
is very much in line with the
things we've been talking about
so far, which we've been
calling the LQR trees, OK.
And the big idea that
happened is that these guys
in LIDS, Pablo Parrilo--
anybody know Pablo?
And Alex [? McGretsky's ?] the
one who taught me about this--
have figured out
new effective ways
to computationally
estimate basins
of attraction of some
classes of controls, OK.
OK, so this is a new thing.
People have been
doing algorithms
to design Lyapunov functions
for at least a decade.
But I think they got really
practical a couple of years ago
in Pablo's thesis, actually.
Think it's two Ls, yeah.
What Pablo did in his thesis
is he promoted this sums
of squares programming.
In fact, you can even
download SoS tools from his--
as a MATLAB package from
his website to do this.
Sums of squares programs
are efficient ways
to check whether a polynomial
function is negative definite,
OK, potentially with free
parameters, and so on.
These can be made--
and these can be
vector variables,
can be made uniformly
negative definite
or semidefinite, OK,
or trivially positive
semidefinite.
Seems like a little--
you can see how it
might be relevant, OK.
So this is just a
mathematical idea
to turn the problem of checking
the positive definiteness
of a polynomial
into a linear matrix
inequality and then a
convex optimization problem.
So I'm not going to go
into all the details,
but know that there's
these tools out there that
use convex optimization to check
that property of a problem, OK.
And you can read more.
I've got links if you want
to read more about that.
What that allows us to do now,
at least in the case of the LQR
design we've worked it out,
it's possible to now check
whether a function,
a polynomial function
is a Lyapunov function
for the system.
Lyapunov functions have to have
their derivatives going down
over time, yeah.
In order for a good function
to be a Lyapunov function,
its value had better be
going down at all times.
If your candidate
Lyapunov function is even
a vector polynomial
function, then you
can use this to check
whether it's a valid Lyapunov
function for your system, OK.
So we can now--
AUDIENCE: [SNEEZE]
PROFESSOR: Bless you.
So I threw this one in
without saying it before.
The only caveat is you have
to take your nonlinear system
and make a polynomial
approximation of it,
a Taylor expansion of it.
It doesn't have
to be first order.
That's the linear system.
But it has to be polynomial, OK.
So suddenly, it turns out
that for the LQR systems--
remember, our value function.
Let's just think of the LTI LQR.
The value function turns out
to be this quadratic form.
It's the optimal cost to go.
That's a Lyapunov function.
J of x for the linear system
is a Lyapunov function.
As I take control
actions, my cost to go
is only going to go down.
It had better, otherwise it's
not the optimal cost to go.
So OK.
If I have a nonlinear
system, where
I've linearized it
and done LQR control,
then I expect that to be--
this function to be a Lyapunov
function over some domain
where the
linearization was good,
and eventually,
to no longer have
this nice negative
definiteness property.
Does that make sense?
The optimal cost to go from
LQR isn't a Lyapunov function
for the entire state.
It's always going to
descend for the entire--
for any initial conditions
for the linear system.
But when I've
linearized the system,
I expect this to
be, J star to be,
a valid Lyapunov function
near the linearization.
You guys should stop
and ask questions
now if you have any questions.
Does that make sense?
I never actually
said before that you
can think of these cost
[? to goes ?] as Lyapunov
functions, but that's
a nice connection
between the optimal control
and the stability theory, OK.
But the cost to go actually
is a Lyapunov function.
Remember, when we're taking
a linearization doing LQR,
we already know that
the basin of attraction
is going to be something finite.
We talked about
that at the Acrobot.
I do a linearization
around the top.
I know if I'm near
that point, it's
got some small finite
basin of attraction.
If I'm inside that region,
it'll go to the goal.
If I'm outside that,
then the linear design,
controller design, isn't valid
for the nonlinear system.
Eventually, you're going to get
far enough away that it's not
going to work.
It's going to--
I think I even
showed a simulation
of it doing something crazy.
So what we did was we designed
a controller that got up there,
and then we turned on
the linear controller.
All was good.
So a different way to say
that exact same thing is
that at some point, when I get
too far from the fixed point,
if I evaluate this function
and look at the time
derivative of this
function, it's
no longer going
to-- my cost is not
going to go down
as time goes up.
And in the case for the
Acrobot, if I'm here
and I start going
this way, then I'm
getting further from my goal.
My cost is going up.
At some point, for
the nonlinear system,
this function is not
going to be a Lyapunov
function for that system, OK.
So what we've got, thanks
to Pablo and [? Sasha ?]
[? McGretzky, ?] is a way
to figure out exactly a--
well, not exactly--
to estimate the place
where that transition
happens using
these sums of squares programs.
My goal here is to tell
you about the existence
of these things, and
I'm happy to push you
more in that direction if you're
interested, for your project
or for whatever.
But we're going to use this
to do the feedback motion
planning, OK.
So it turns out J is a scalar.
My cost to go is a scalar.
It turns out I can very
succinctly describe the place
where this-- a boundary
of this function--
let me just write it, and
then I'll say it carefully.
I can describe a
region of my system
just by looking at the
height of my cost to go.
This is a quadratic function.
It's going to look like
ellipsoids going out.
If you were to draw
this landscape,
it's going to look like
an ellipse, a parabola
in high dimensions, yeah.
At some point, as I move
farther from my fixed point,
the cost is going to get
higher and higher, OK.
And at some point, it crosses
some scalar value rho.
So the way I want
to design, I want
to call my basin of
attraction for this system
the place where my
cost to go reaches rho.
And we've got a program, thanks
to [? Sasha and ?] Pablo,
which will try to estimate this
scalar value, rho, as a scalar
representative of the basin
of attraction of my system.
AUDIENCE: Why would you
use a particular cost
to go rather than looking
at what the variation is
in the linearization?
PROFESSOR: That is-- so
we're going to determine this
by looking at the variation
based on the linearization.
So I could do this in a
lot of different ways.
I could look at boxes
around my fixed point
and try to design some geometry.
The real basin of
attraction is going
to be some complicated
thing, which
depends on my LQR controller
design and the way
the non-linearity affects.
AUDIENCE: Right, but wouldn't--
so I guess what would seem more
intuitive to me would be to say,
look at the next highest order
term in the expansion and then
see how that's varying and use
that to--
PROFESSOR: That's exactly how
we're going to verify it, OK.
So there's two questions.
There's a question
of what shapes are
we going to try to verify, OK.
The choice here is
to verify contours
of the cost to go function.
I'm going to try to find the
biggest contour of the cost
to go function for
the linear system.
You're asking if I could
choose a different shape based
on the contours.
What we've elected
to do-- and I think
it's a tighter version, maybe,
than what you're saying,
but I could be wrong.
There could be better ways--
is to find the biggest contour
such that the next higher order
terms of the
linearization don't break
the negative definiteness.
AUDIENCE: OK, so this
is just for purposes
of choosing a shape.
PROFESSOR: This is
choosing my shape, OK.
So I'm going to make this
all concrete right now
by trying to show
you an example here.
OK, here's a simple pendulum,
which we know and love, OK.
This is the phase portrait
of the simple pendulum.
OK, and the green is at
0, 0, which, in this case,
is my downward fixed point.
The top is my
unstable fixed point.
My goal is to use these local
trajectory ideas in order
to cover--
to make all states
go to them, OK.
Now all I told you so far is I
know how to take an LQR problem
and try to estimate the
basin of attraction, OK.
So that's step one, is take a
linearization around my goal
state, estimate-- design
an LQR controller,
and estimate it's basin
of attraction, OK.
And that looks like this, OK.
We've seen cost to go
functions for the ellipsoids,
or ellipsoids around
the fixed point.
I do a sums of
square optimization
to verify that this function
is negative definite, which
involves a higher order
polynomial expansion
of the dynamics in this form.
And I try to find the biggest
contour for which that system
is still negative definite.
That's all the detail.
All you really need to know
is that I can estimate now,
with convex optimization,
the basin of attraction
of that system.
This is Koditschek's
funnel at the top.
That blue region is the
beginning of the funnel.
In this case, I'm going
to run it infinitely long,
so it's going to eventually
get to the red point.
That's the output.
OK, now how do we design funnels
that try to fill this space?
OK, my proposition is
that we should do roughly
what the RRTs are doing
and start growing out
to try to cover the space in
lots of different directions,
OK.
The only difference
is, every time
we grow out in
random directions,
I'm going to stabilize that
trajectory with an LTV feedback
and compute the basin
of attraction on it, OK.
So here we go.
Pick a point at random, OK.
And actually, I'm not--
I don't always
play the RRT trick.
So I could do lots of RRTs to
try to get back to that point,
but I'm actually going to
just use this as my goal
and do [? DR call ?] to get me
there, to design a trajectory
to get me there.
If that works, that's
perfectly fine.
So that's a trajectory.
I didn't draw it nicely.
It actually starts
here, goes this way,
wraps around, and comes
to that red point, OK.
From [? DR ?] call, it quickly
designs that trajectory.
Now let's back up and
start computing the cost
to go function, the
Riccati equation,
backwards to stabilize
that trajectory.
And as we go, we'll
compute the basin
of attraction of that
controller, which has exactly--
I drew it in finite
segments, but I
hope you can see that's
exactly the funnels, yeah?
If I start the system inside
any of that blue region,
and I execute the
trajectory, the LQR,
the trajectory stabilizer
along that trajectory,
it's going to take me
around and get me to my goal
and stay there, OK.
So this is feedback
motion planning happening.
Now the cool thing is, I told
you about the multi-query idea.
I told you about
all these ideas,
talked about making
very dense trees that
handle all these situations.
If you know the basins of
attraction of your existing
controller, you don't have
to build a very dense tree.
I know, if I were to pick
another random point that
was already inside
my blue region,
I'm not going to
get a lot of value
out of adding nodes
inside that blue region.
So let's pick
another random point,
and if it's inside the blue
region, we'll throw it away.
If it's outside, I'll keep it,
and I'll try to grow to it, OK.
So I get another random
point, which is here.
Going to pick the closest
point in my current tree, which
was just, in this case, a
trajectory, connect that back.
Now in this one, my
dynamic distance metric,
which was that LQR
distance metric,
connected and said this
was the closest point.
Looks a little surprising,
but maybe the torque
limits said that one
couldn't get there,
or maybe my distance
metric just wasn't perfect.
But that's reasonable.
It tries to go from here,
add a little bit more torque,
and drive out.
And I stabilize that
with the funnel, yeah?
OK, now I have two
trajectories, and I've
got a pretty good coverage
of the space already.
You can imagine I design a
handful more trajectories,
picking the state as
I go, and I can really
quickly and efficiently fill
that state space with funnels
which take me to the goal.
Does that makes sense?
AUDIENCE: So when you
do your multi-query,
how do you choose
which funnel you're in?
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
Well, first, even-- so if I
just want to execute this, yeah.
And I want to get
to that goal, it
might be that I
don't really have
to do the-- so you could think
of this as being every time
being a multi-query thing.
So every time I--
if I start, if I
pick a point that isn't in
any basin of attraction,
then I'll try to connect
and grow a tree there.
If I, however, pick a point--
if it's execution
time, I say the robot's
got to run from
here, I pick a point.
It's already in the
basin of attraction
that I just execute
that trajectory.
If, I think what
you're alluding to
is that it's in the basin of
attraction of multiple points,
then I pick the one with
the lowest cost to go,
because those are all
estimates of the cost
to go that are centered
around that trajectory, OK.
So for the simple pendulum,
with damping and torque limits
and everything set
the way it was,
this little randomized
algorithm can fill the space
with basins of attraction with
just a handful of trajectories.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I've never
said it with so much--
[LAUGHTER]
--such dramatic force.
OK?
[CHUCKLES] It's the highlight
of the class right here.
OK, so this is exactly the
feedback motion planning idea
that I'm most excited
about right now.
Because we can suddenly--
for LQR controller,
it depended on--
the thing we've worked out
is, if the cost to go function
is this, or in the time
varying case, this,
then I can come up with a
very nice representation
of the basin of attraction
based on just a scalar value.
And I could just start designing
funnels through my state space.
And the vision is, if you
can think about the funnels
as you build them,
then you actually
don't have to build
too many trajectories
to start filling
the state space.
AUDIENCE: Why do you call
it feedback motion planning.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's because I'm thinking about
the feedback control, which
is the funnel, as I'm
doing the planning.
Yeah.
Do you agree why Koditschek's
version is feedback motion
planning, or do you not like
that being feedback motion
planning?
AUDIENCE: It makes sense.
I guess I'm used to
different funnels.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
You are, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLES]
PROFESSOR: OK?
AUDIENCE: [? Think ?] [? so. ?]
PROFESSOR: So these
are very much--
in Koditschek's case,
there's no debate
that each funnel is a
feedback controller.
I think of this as the same way.
You could argue with
it, because it's
centered around trajectory
design, which his is not.
So this one has
a little bit more
of a feel of conventional
motion planning.
But by virtue of thinking
about the feedback
as I design the
trajectories, it means
I have to build less
trajectories, yeah.
So it'd be nice to actually
have the conversation about how
these are related
to float tubes.
Mm-hmm.
It's pretty similar
in some ways.
But these are very
effective to compute
the stable-- the
basins of attraction,
so I think it's relevant.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you
factor in actuator limits
into the Lyapunov function?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So OK, actuator limits in the
Lyapunov function are harder.
So what you do is
you-- everything
is based on a Taylor
expansion of the dynamics
around the nominal.
So a hard limit, if I linearize
and I don't see that limit,
then I'm not going
to know about it.
So there's a couple
things you could try.
And actually, I recommended
to Mike earlier today
that he should do this
for his final project,
is to do that, the case
where the actuator limits.
So you could imagine
making a soft limit,
some sigmoidal limit,
and having the gradients
of that visible from
your linearization point.
Or you could imagine
the LQR design
that actually does both the
quadratic cost and the bang
bang synonymously.
Haven't done it yet, but
I think that's consistent.
OK, so I told you a lot about
local trajectory optimizers.
And today we said there were
at least three good ways,
I think, to make those
trajectory optimizers
into a more feedback plan.
So the first idea was
real time planning.
And if it's fast
enough, well, then we're
all out of jobs, because
we could just do that.
The second idea was
building these trees
and doing multi-query,
keeping your tree around
and just finding your way to
the closest point of the tree
every time you execute.
And that has the nice feature
that every time I execute,
my tree gets a
little bit bigger,
and I know a little bit more
about my robot and myself,
yeah.
And the last one was this
feedback motion planning,
which there are only
a handful of ideas
out there, I think, about
feedback motion planning
that people use.
Koditschek's funnels are
definitely the most prominent.
And actually, I think that
the funnels should probably be
on my list, but I haven't--
sorry, the float tubes should
probably be more on my list,
but I don't--
I've never made a strong
enough connection.
We should make that a goal for
the rest of the class, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
float tube or--
PROFESSOR: So there's
definitely differences,
but we should really
figure it out.
So [? Brian ?] [? Williams' ?]
group does planning with float
tubes that are, in spirit,
similar to these funnels.
Yeah.
And so we should talk
about whether you
can design the float tubes
for the class of systems
that I care about in
the class and stuff.
Mm-hmm.
Excellent.
OK, so you saw the email
about the projects.
If you have any questions
about your projects,
we could talk for
a minute right now,
or we could schedule a
meeting before Thursday.
There's a few ideas on the
email we sent in the PDF
that we sent out.
If you're looking
for more ideas,
I've got a list of other
ideas that I'm happy to share.
It's going to work best if
you find a problem that you're
passionate about,
something that you
got excited about in
class or from your work,
and you apply some
idea from class.
But the goal for Thursday
is to say enough about it
that I can give you
some real feedback
on your half-page
write-up and try
to help you with the
scope and topic to make it
a good project.
OK?
Let me know if
there's any questions.
See you Thursday.